do you like one wack really Bob nearly
had a freezing before how hard is it to
use a lightsaber
it's corruption dick yes yes same see
grinder okay Luke grind Walker long side
DJ Binks Aki boba scared
and we have lad Bible to interview Daisy
Ridley why cuz we're Jedi's yeah yeah
yeah it's coming out so I'm doing it
right again made a force be with you
sorry Daisy what's the like men in Star
Wars pretty good thanks yes cool do you
reckon we could get on the next
soundtrack for the Star Wars film you'll
have to talk to JJ but I could hook you
up if you'd like that yeah new tracks I
like that yes perfect good answer
continuing so do you think you will ever
go to space in real life maybe I mean if
the world like combusts unclear it might
yeah maybe we'll all have to go there
alive I'd rather die yeah and just
there's quite intense there yeah yeah
it's just yeah I know actually someone
who's building a nuclear bunker yeah but
why would you want to only survive the
three of you in the world exactly yeah
how hard is it to use a lightsaber it's
it's pretty hard it's not check this one
yeah check this wow that sounds it oh
sorry in this wicked
are you would you stop that at any point
have it go how'd it go hey that one I
can't hit no no you don't mind sir how
about you why is it okay man oh yeah do
more but I feel like I should only make
it equal there we go it's good enough
sick in it and they fill it up it's not
hot so it's fine we did think a lot of
the times why are you so heavy
yeah yeah is that more because they're
trying to train you your arms maybe cuz
I got hurt yes have you lost all that
nur yeah I'm not okay right next
question would Chui be your laughs on a
night out like I said she was the
lightweight yeah but you'd be a fun
lightweight cool but taking him home
would be difficult cause he's big do you
like one all courage if so who's your
favourite gauge will grind that across
the fence I was in Y nice means even
well you know they call him the
Godfather yeah I'm actually got Bob
Rizzo is exactly stop yeah I mean if you
can why not exactly but yeah I was in
one his music video so I said well part
of the grime theme which one lights out
if you had to pick who your favorite is
who would it be
yeah yeah and we are yeah FM get it they
don't know they know those people do
know yeah yeah she's just trying to keep
you humble can you do a wookie
impression no no move on cuz granddad's
loads of weird experiences with friends
yeah yeah yeah actually famously had
nearly had a threesome people recognize
you not all the time
I'm actually a big fan of your cousin
tree work yes yeah
so usually a geek people want it's my
new boys that come up to us and say do
you want to come back and play fifa oh
really yeah
I've nearly had freezing before good for
you
but not fun rowing man in it yeah yeah
what is your favorite color
they say gray oh I like that
I know I don't know if it says something
about me as a person I was really like
gray really like dark know like I'd like
a mid humid hue I'm more into turquoise
oh nice yeah
till they call it these days I think
they're two different colors tells the
new name for temple three two one
MC Grindr man like bees and Daisy so
named most famous works start wars and
casually and while a video so no like
Bible by it now you can't buy that bug
well you just go now and buy Star Wars
as well yeah yeah it's good Wow
and then just cut yet just before I got
that camera what did you see that see
what everyone felt attention to as you
fancy me ah can't believe it but I can't
believe it but sometimes it's still a
surprising it still got it
yeah it's probably casually
plus I'm a shy I would never do anything
but good to know that Daisy would be
fancy to me